a star NFL running back getting no jail
time for last year's brutal beating here
in Las Vegas New Orleans Saints star
Alvin Kamara pleading no contest to a
misdemeanor today the 8 news now and now
and Gators have been all over the story
since kamar's arrest last year Kyle
Payne joining us now with the details
Kyle
Denise Bryan first a warning some of
this video is disturbing this is another
serious high profile case here in Clark
County and another high-profile
defendant who won't see jail time this
time Alvin Kamara wasn't even in court
so tomorrow's not present that's correct
really not present the NFL superstar
Alvin Kamara handing off today's hearing
to his attorneys who emerge from behind
closed doors with a friendly deal Kamara
will do no jail time we'll pay his
victim about a hundred and five thousand
dollars for past medical expenses and
pay a 500 fine plus he'll do 30 hours of
community service which he has to finish
in 90 days he was initially charged with
two felonies now this will be a
misdemeanor charge for breach of peace
right now putting an end to the criminal
matter that left this victim with his
face beaten so badly that it broke the
bone around his eyeball and he had to
have shoulder surgery I kind of figured
oh they got into some trouble and
they're just trying to get away from it
in an exclusive interview with eight
news now investigator David charns
kamara's Driver explained the aftermath
of the beating it was so fast-paced it
was so quick uh just me looking at him
like to me it's just like wow wow is
also a good word to describe some of
what Kamara and his co-defendants who
also took similar plea deals with no
jail time were saying that night in more
video first obtained by 8 news now
hear him here you hear Kamara sitting
behind the driver making what
prosecutors refer to as an admission of
guilt
these videos were key evidence
prosecutors used in getting a grand jury
to indict Kamara and the others for that
four on one beating and stomping but now
it's case closed
uh honorary request to close the case
police arrested three other men for that
beating including fellow NFL player
Chris lammons who's a free agent those
three took similar plea deals none will
do any jail time we asked kamar's lawyer
for a statement or comment and we didn't
hear from them by the time of this
broadcast the NFL sent me a statement
which reads quote we have been closely
monitoring all developments in the
matter which remains under review Denise
all right Kyle thanks for that we can
also tell you that on Instagram today
the victim's attorney announced that his
10 million dollar civil lawsuit has been
settled those terms though are
confidential you can see more on this
story and kamara's written apology to
the victim on our website 8newsnow.com
Brian